on en parlait en début d'émission le
musée de la ville de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines lance une
nouvelle exposition autour de l'espace
où on retrouve sur place notre
journaliste Nicolas dandry bonsoir
Nicolas
bonsoir Mathilde vous êtes avec le
conservateur du musée de Monsieur debuch
et alors est-ce qu'on peut voir au sein
de cette exposition Nicolas
et bien écoutez le musée de la ville de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines nous plonge
nous plonge pardon dans le spaceage
quand la conquête spatiale inspire le
design et bien écoutez en fait à la fin
des années de guerre de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale la conquête spatiale est
lancée et inspire le design les produits
du quotidien et pour en parler nous
sommes avec Frédéric de Bush le
directeur du musée de la ville bonjour
bonjour
alors on peut découvrir différents
objets du quotidien des canapés des
objets aussi de télévision des radios
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire ce que
c'est le spaceage oui alors on rentre
directement dans le vif du sujet alors
le Space Age c'est tout simplement
le design qui est inspirait le design ou
l'architecture aspiré par la conquête de
l'espace vous savez que la conquête de
l'espace a été un grand moment de
fascination qui qui démarre dans les
années d'après-guerre surtout à partir
des années 50 le premier Spoutnik 1er
satellite artificiel en 57 le premier
homme dans l'espace en 1961 et le
premier pas de l'homme sur la Lune en
1969 donc tout ça exerce une fascination
assez importante et les designers les
créateurs vont vouloir s'emparer des
thématiques liées à l'espace sous des
formes très très diverses et là on voit
un objet surprenant alors là vous voyez
par exemple des des fauteuils avec une
table inspirée alors l'inspiration
finalement c'est cette forme ronde de
qui rappelle l'espace alors pas
seulement nous on a voulu rappeler
qu'elle peut-être les différentes formes
d'inspiration et à travers ces exemples
on a déjà voulu commencer par le nom
puisque on a ici des exemples d'un
designer qui s'appelle Cazarre et qui a
créé une gamme qui s'appelle Aerospace
et qui consiste notamment de mobilier
gonflable et donc on est dans la
thématique de l'air de l'aérien et avec
cette esthétique aussi qui est tout à
fait tout à fait spécifique mais autre
objet et la table nuage d'un autre d'un
autre designer nuage parce que voilà on
voulait aussi rappeler que la conquête
de l'espace était d'abord un élan vers
le cosmos vers le ciel et vers
autre objet assez surprenant et bien
c'est cette télévision parce que oui
c'est une télévision voilà c'est
exactement c'est une télévision c'est un
objet qui est assez explicite de ce que
peut et assez démonstratif de ce que
peut être le spacege avec là une
aspiration vraiment très directe alors
c'est une télévision japonaise
créée par un designer qui s'appelle tout
ça et qui a qui c'est tout simplement
inspiré du casque du cosmonaute donc la
télé est parfaitement ronde et devant
l'écran il y a une visière bombée dans
un plexiglas un petit peu plus fumé qui
rappelle évidemment le casque du cosmet
c'est aussi une télé qui avait la
particularité de d'être portatif qui
pouvait être déplacé d'une pièce à
l'autre de la maison et qui peut être
suspendu par le biais d'une chaîne et
donc on l'imagine dans une pièce en
suspension et là elle prend plus
tellement l'allure d'un casque de de
cosmonaute mais plutôt d'une planète qui
serait en suspension dans l'espace ce
qui surprenant c'est que ça date des
années 70 alors cette télé date
précisément de 1970 et donc elle a été
conçue l'année précédente en 69
exactement elle est donc sa conception
est exactement contemporaine de la
mission Apollo 11 qui a vu la conquête
de la Lune et c'est sans doute en lien
direct avec cette aventure que le
designer japonais a conçu cette
télévision ce qui rappelle aussi
[Musique]
merci beaucoup Frédéric debuche voilà
Mathilde sur cette exposition au musée
de la ville sur le Space Age je sais que
vous êtes passionné par le sujet spatial
Mathilde je sais que vous souhaitez y
aller et bien et je vais vous donner
tout de suite les informations vous
pouvez y aller si vous êtes intéressé
par cette exposition à partir du 10
février et c'est jusqu'au 8 juillet
c'est ouvert le mardi le mercredi le
vendredi et le samedi de 14h à 18h
l'entrée est gratuite alors ben
maintenant il y a plus qu'à plonger dans
les étoiles
merci beaucoup Nicolas dandry pour
toutes ces précisions